it's the first week of june and you know
what that means it's time for another dr
sather channel update so in this one i'm
going to talk about what we did during
the month of may which was very
important and busy month
and what we've got lined up for the
month of june a month in which i'll
actually get a little bit of vacation
but where we've got a lot of other
interesting stuff lined up as well
so we passed an important milestone in
may and i shot a video about that so i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna go into any
depth about it i've got the link uh in
the description for this video
and that milestone was a million views
so for a philosophy focused channel
that's kind of a big thing you know if
we were doing
uh little kitty cats or animal attacks
or
you know
who knows what else uh people getting
hit in the groin that would not be a
very big
very large number of views but for
philosophy videos some of which are you
know an hour an hour and a half long
that's kind of a a big thing
so
i talked in that that video um about
some of the things we're going to roll
out this fall
none of those are happening in june so
i'm going to kind of skip over those
here
um what else happened in in may well
marist classes came to a close the
face-to-face classes
and not long after that
my online class with marist began i
teach an online 10-week ethics class in
the summer and i often teach a four-week
ethics class in the
winter session
although i don't know whether that's
going to happen this time around
and i've already got you know 31
students enrolled
we just finished our first week
and it's it's going you know fairly well
i had to actually send out the the email
notices to a bunch of students saying
hey you know online doesn't mean
correspondence you gotta gotta
participate a bit more
we did two glimpses into existence
existentialism series lectures at the
kingston public library this month in
part because the weird scheduling in
april how easter fell and all the other
things that we had going on
so
we did a nietzsche one at the beginning
and arika won just this last weekend
we're getting more people coming to them
they're starting to really get some some
traction in the local community in the
hudson valley and it's a lot of fun some
of the same people are showing up
lecture after lecture and and there's
some continuity to the discussions as a
result
we did a philosophy forum with rob skiff
from aplerno which is a for-profit
educational company which is uh really
putting adjuncts in the driver's seat
not only for
developing class content but for paying
a living wage i did the breakdown on how
much
the
college classes that i'm teaching online
not for a player know
cost the students and how much of that i
actually receive
and it was less than ten percent of what
they they charge those students i
actually get paid so all the rest is
going to overhead in one form or or
another
with the player know i get 80 percent
which is really extraordinary so
we can afford to charge less much much
less for the class
and have smaller classes and still
make a better
living because we don't have to pay all
these administrators and staff and this
and that
and you know build build beautiful
buildings for the college it it's a way
to actually make things center once
again around the teacher and the student
the way it ought to be in education
so that was a really cool discussion
that we had we talked about student
loans we talked about the plight of
adjuncts we talked about where education
is going we talked about online
platforms
covered a lot of ground
i did another theology matters with the
pelus that's a radio show that
i've been contributing to
showing up as a guest talking about
various
christian philosophers and sometimes the
the atheist bad boy philosophers too we
did one on david hume back in the fall
this time it was on saint augustine and
his conception of evil as privation
i also did a uh some segments on the
punk rock philosopher show another radio
show that broadcasts on saturday nights
and in that one
we have been talking um about the
beginnings of phenomenology so i've been
i've been uh helping out with some some
discussions about hegel
so that's a good lead into the video
work for for may
if you missed any of these these videos
you can find them in the playlist or you
can find them in the video feed
we finished up the religion in america
class that i was teaching at marist
college all of those lectures are are
now done
and they're they're available in a
playlist you know some of them are about
40 minutes some of them are about 20
minutes
if you want to
get a sort of broad overview of the the
history
and the cultural importance of religions
in america because it's plural
you might want to check that out if you
do you probably want to buy the textbook
that we used in the course which is
pretty cheap you can get it for about 35
40 bucks i think
we really stepped up things with the
half hour hegel series that's rolling
along pretty nicely now
and i'm going to be releasing those
throughout the summer
we're now
knee-deep in the middle of the preface
of the phenomenology a very exciting
place to be
did a few more 10 shorts videos
these don't get an awful lot of views
but but viewers seem to
be you know excited the ones who do
watch it about getting their their
questions
addressed or sometimes even answered
so i'm going to keep on doing those
uh we did some core concept videos i i
thought well since i'm working on on
augustine
with these radio shows i may as well
shoot some augustine core concept videos
and uh i'm gonna keep on doing that
and of course we recorded the glimpses
into existence videos the one on nature
the one on on rilka so that brings that
lecture series to five now it's uh it'll
be 12 all together that you could
actually
use is kind of like a mini study course
so
that leads us up to where we are now
it's early on enough in june that i can
i can really talk quite a bit about june
without having to do some backtracking
this is a month where i'll actually get
to take some vacation i'll get to go to
the beach for about a week with my my
wife and kids
we try to do that once a year
going going out to
montauk before the the season really
starts so the water is a little cold
but the beach isn't crowded and it's a
really nice way to relax for for us
um
and
what else have i got going on before
that there's the saint anselm
metaphysics colloquium up at st anselm
college i'll be going up there at that
one i don't have to talk although i will
of course talk because i always get
involved with chatting about things but
i don't have to do any presentations
they already have speakers for that and
i can just go and really just be a
student and and meet up with some old
friends
uh i've been going to saint anselm's
college since uh 2000 for for one
conference or another
now i'm up there about once or twice a
year
um what else is going on
i'm still in the process of building
more content for my existentialism class
that i'm i'm constructing for a plano
and i i've rethought some of the things
particularly for the early weeks how i
want the material to be lined up for
students i've said that a plareno puts
the instructor in the driver's seat as
far as the design of the class and that
can be a good thing but it can also be
you know something that leads to
things taking a bit longer if you if you
give it to somebody like me who's always
wanting to say well you know what if i
did this or what if i did that what if i
added this in what if i added that in
so
that should be coming out
i should be submitting it for for its
first review sometime this month
i'm also writing a
book chapter on on jacques laca and
ethics this month and i have just
finished with a
textbook proposal which i'm submitting
to to a textbook publisher
i had to write some some sample material
in this case the sample material was on
aristotle and happiness and the idea was
to write it in such a way that students
today can relate to it so i've drawn on
a lot of things from my my classes
um
i'll be doing another glimpses of
existence session
at the kingston public library at the
end of the month this time on the
russian philosopher lev shestoff a very
interesting existentialist
i'm doing in other theology matters
later this week on thursday night
and this one will be on the existence
and nature of god the way that augustine
understands these things which are you
know kind of interrelated with each
other
i'll be doing some more punk rock
philosopher segments some of which will
be on hegel's phenomenology some of
which we started getting into some
discussions about alexander kojov's
introduction to the reading of hegel
we're going to do another dr sailors
philosophy forum later this month but i
haven't decided
whether i want to do a guest or whether
i want to do one on my own
perhaps on existentialism
and i'm not sure exactly when i'm going
to do it it won't be it won't be this
coming weekend
uh and and so things are a little bit up
in the air for that so you know stay
stay tuned for that now videos we have a
lot of videos coming out this month more
half hour hegel
uh
more core concept videos these i'm
actually taking the opportunity to
produce more core concept videos for my
my own marist class students so some of
them are going to be on wd ross is the
right and the good
and his prima facie duties i did two of
them previously and i'd like to do the
other five some of them are on parts of
aristotle's nick and mccain ethics that
i hadn't gotten to before
like uh book five where he's talking
about about justice so i've done done
some core concept videos on that i'll do
another 10 shorts or maybe two this
month we'll see how many questions i get
and then i know i've been promising to
get to some existentialism videos but
it's been a matter of finding the time
but i'm ready to start shooting some on
kafka
and
perhaps even
we'll see how it goes for this month
perhaps even on dostoevsky's work the
demons or the possessed
so that's what we got going on uh
this coming month
you know i'm going to be taking a little
bit of down time
probably releasing some of the videos
during that time
and
enjoying my time with my my wife and
kids and while the weather is still you
know
mild before it becomes
unbearably hot and humid and i have to
dig out the air conditioner
so i hope that you'll watch some of
these
share some of the videos
tune in to the things that that interest
you maybe the theology matters or the
half the the um
punk rock philosopher if you're in the
area
and you're free
on on saturday uh mornings
then consider at the end of the month
popping in for my glimpses of existence
session on lev chest off
otherwise have a good month and uh
you'll see plenty of my face if you're
tuned in to my feed